>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Eiichi Ito: Good afternoon,
welcome to the Library
of Congress.
We are delighted that all
of you are here today,
today's program lecture
entitled A Story
of Layers the Artisan Hands
that make Japanese Woodblock
Prints by Dr. Clair Cuccio.
I'm Eiichi Ito, I'm one of
the two reference librarians
in the Asian Division at
the Library of Congress.
This program will be recorded
and the webcast later.
So, now it's a good time to
turn off your mobile devices
if you haven't done so yet.
And please note that any
questions that you ask
at the end of the
talk will be recorded
and merely asking the question
constitutes the permission
for us to record
and the broadcasting
over the internet later.
Before introducing
today's speaker now I'd
like to invite Dr.
Dongfang Shao,
the chief of Asian
Division to say a few words.
Dr. Shao.
>> Dongfang Shao:
Good afternoon.
I am happy we have a
full house here today.
Earlier our lecture had less
audience in the past yeah.
And this lecture is cosponsored
by Asian Division and also Print
and Photo Division,
two divisions cosponsor
this lecture.
And also, this lecture is
part of Asian Division 2018,
Asian study lecture series
celebrating the 90th anniversary
of Asian Division,
the founding yeah.
Asian division was created
by Congress in 1928.
At that time in 1928 it
was called the Division
of Chinese Literature and in
1931 it changed to the Division
of Chinese and Japanese
Literature.
And we got the Asian
Division name in 1978 yeah.
So, Asian Division is one
of the four major we call
ever studied divisions
in the Library of Congress.
Yeah, we are the largest Asian
collection outside of Asia
that houses about more than 2
million physical items yeah,
including 28 countries
and areas in East Asia,
South Asia and Southeast Asia.
This area consists more
than 60% of world population
and also several
Asian civilizations.
Asian Division directly supports
the library's strategy goals
to acquire and maintain
the knowledge
and the record of
Asian countries.
We collect the material to
support to meet the needs
of first Congress,
second researchers
and third, the American public.
And our holding basically
are vernacular languages
in 179 languages in Asia.
And we also have the largest,
a very large rare collection
almost 50,000 books yeah,
rare books published
in Asian countries.
And among these collections
the largest one is Japanese
collection with 1.2 million
items about Japanese culture,
history in Japanese languages.
In recent years you know
we have acquired a lot
of electronic resources in
addition to the physical items.
And the electronic resources
have gained increased importance
in our collection.
In addition to acquire the
vendors' databases we have been
doing the digitization
of our own collections.
One of the major recent
achievements is the digitization
of Japanese censorship
material collection.
That was available
online just recently yeah,
there are several thousand
Japanese censorship books has
been represented.
And so, we worked for this
project almost seven years yeah.
So, in general, we have the
users using our reading room,
our reading room is
in the other building,
the Jefferson Hall, room 150.
So, I hope all of you,
you know, have an interest
in Asian studies, particular
Japanese study can use our Asian
reading room yeah and everybody
above 16 years old can
get a registration card
from the main reading room
and use our collection.
Our reading room
is open from 8:30
to 5 p.m. Monday to Friday yeah.
So, when you visit our
[inaudible] don't forget
to visit Asian reading room,
at least you have a tour there.
Now I turn over to Eiichi
to introduce our collection
about wood prints and
also our speaker today.
>> Eiichi Ito: The Asian
division holds more
than 300 woodblock
art and picture books
from the [inaudible] period.
Notable among these are
the 15-volume collection
of [inaudible] and the artist
behind the iconic great wave
of Kanagawa.
And also, the Prints and the
Photographs Division collection
include about 2,500 examples,
including [inaudible] prints
which was developed in Edo now
Tokyo during the Tokugawa period
1600 to 1868.
[Inaudible] prints
are from 1868 to 1912.
Modern woodblock prints from
the [inaudible] or new prints
and [inaudible] created prints
that dominated the Japanese
printmaking through the 1960's.
And the [inaudible]
through the 21st century.
Now today's speaker Dr.
Clair Cuccio earned the PhD
in Japanese literature
from Stanford University
and is an independent scholar of
the East Asian Woodblock Prints
and the print culture.
She's country based
in Washington,
DC after a long period
of residence
in China, Japan, and Taiwan.
She has lectured at the Beijing
Foreign Languages University,
Western Academy of
Beijing, Kyoto Consortium
for Japanese Studies at
the Doshisha University,
and Bank Art 1929
in Yokohama, Japan.
And she served as
chair of the board
for the International Mokuhanga
Conference 2017, last year.
Her articles Translations
and Collaborations encompass
traditional woodblock artisans
and their training in
unique hand practices,
as well as contemporary artists
working in prints and paper.
She also published her own
portrait focusing on art,
language, transnational culture,
and multiple identities.
So today, Dr. Cuccio will
discuss how Japanese woodblock
prints are created by means
of network of multiple artists
in the process that
combines individual expertise
and collaborative production.
Following the lecture, a
number of materials drawn
from the Asian Division and the
Prints and Photographs Division
to illustrate an array of
artistic and technical qualities
of the Japanese prints will
be displayed just outside
[inaudible] theater in the foyer
as you leave the auditorium.
Thanks to Kathleen Black,
Prints and Photograph Division
and also Cameron Penwell
for assembling the materials
for display working
with Dr. Cuccio.
Important request here, I have
to say this because I more
or less get excited to see some
beautiful material I attempted
to touch or ort of flip the
pages, but we appreciate it
if you can approach the display
without any food and drink
on hand and not touching
the display
as you enjoy viewing the
material in the foyer.
Now please welcome Dr. Cuccio.
[ Applause ]
>> Clair Cuccio: Good
afternoon everyone.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Clair Cuccio: The Library
of Congress and the topic
of my lecture intersect
in my mind as sights
of humble and honest inquiry.
So, I feel enormous gratitude
today that I can be a part
of this public programming
and particularly
in this multisource approach
where my talk is only a pathway
as apparent by the larger
frame of all of this
to the extraordinary
collections here at the library.
And for the particular works
that the Asian Division
specialist Eiichi Ito
who was just speaking
and the curator
of fine prints Catherine, you're
still back there in the corner,
carefully [inaudible] today,
they don't often
reach public eyes.
So, thank you for
that meticulous
and very patient approach to
a beautiful subject matter.
And to Eiichi in particular,
thank you for bringing me
into the fold of the Asian
library in my peripatetic life.
It's always been an institution
that has remained a
place I can come back to,
along with the staff
who have grown with it,
and it is gratifying that
some things stay the same.
But some things improve, Cameron
Penwell who was just mentioned,
is reasonably new to
the Asian library.
I thank him for his
kindness and professionalism
in putting this together.
And also for Cynthia Wayne who's
one of the exhibition creators
for the overall Library of
Congress, she's a dear friend
of a dear friend who first spoke
with Catherine Blood [phonetic],
and her knowledge
and enthusiasm.
So, thank you to all of you.
And to all of you right in front
of me, thank you for coming.
I hope this is a respite from
the vagaries of daily life
and this is not a
passive moment for you.
I'm here as much to receive
feedback and inquiries and input
from all of you, so thank you.
A Story in Layers
the Artisan Hands
that Make Japanese
Woodblock Prints.
Making has become increasingly
invisible, take some examples
of millennial making,
microchips, wear circuitry
on their exterior, but their
machine built panels are
so miniature they go
undetected by the naked eye.
State-of-the-art kitchen
utensils we handle daily.
such as cookware and knives
reflect aesthetic design.
Yet how they are
made is imperceptible
to the majority of users.
Digital images on
our devices reformat
into uniform pixels
the diverse mediums,
for instance National
Gallery's favorite Renoirs,
girl with the watering can,
Mark Bradford's mixed-media
installation,
which some of you may have
seen, Pickett's charge recently
on display and at Hirshhorn,
and here at the libraries we'll
see this afternoon afterwards
Hokusai's iconic woodblock
print, great wave off Kanagawa
which needs no introduction.
The pixilation of which severs
viewers from engagement with all
but the visual image often
fleeting or distorted at that.
At least for now coding
sequences for images
that are foreign
languages for IT,
safer IT specialists obscure
the size, depth, texture,
color palette, individual
materials and even movement
if you think of someone
like Calder.
And the smell, I mean
prints have a good smell,
they have smell of glue
and inks in the papers.
Elements that reveal the
making behind an object
and the hands invested
in its production.
Reaction to this trend
is trendy and various.
Richard Sennett's The Craftsman
and Matthew Crawford's
Shop Class
as Soulcraft have explored the
benefits of physical skills
and apprenticeship
culture presaging
or prompting a resurgence
in education about the value
of specialized handwork.
On the ground maker
spaces involve dimensions,
outgrowths of the vibrant maker
movement satisfying an appetite
for making from carpentry
to robots,
organic materials
to recycled parts.
More specific to the art world,
in response to the restricted
experience of digitized works
of art, research and development
of haptic technologies
to enable experiencing the
tactile qualities of an object
in digital form is
similarly vigorous.
This expiration of making
points to intrinsic value
in the handcrafted object itself
so ubiquitous today in Japan,
especially as well as here
where glossy magazines
and aesthetic books
fetishize the handmade.
Known familiarly as ukiyo-e
traditional Japanese woodblock
prints like Hokusai's wave
encompass visually complex
and technically refined prints
roughly of the Edo period 1615
to 1848 and then into the
modern period thereafter
for 50 or so years.
They fall into the broad
category of invisible making,
that is to many viewers today
the mastery that ukiyo-e exhibit
in combining materials and
techniques is both inscrutable
and unimaginable not because
these images are mechanically
reproduced, but because
they are wrought so finally
by a multitude of hands skilled
in diverse tools, materials
and methods that uninformed
viewers cannot apprehend
their process.
And so, traditional
woodblock print editions
of ukiyo-e today can often
be mistaken as machine prints
or even machine reproductions
of paintings.
That is why master printer Keizo
Sato or excuse me Sato Keizo
of Sato Woodblock Studio in
Kyoto insists that engagement
with actual artworks ensures
the best form of study.
That is also why
Sato reaches for one
of his studio's favorite
printings
of Hiroshige's landscape, a
view of Naruto at Awa province
to demonstrate his point.
Apart from its production notes,
commissioned in the early 1970's
by a Tokyo publisher
for an initial order
of 70 prints completed by
one carver and five printers
and pulled 12 to 16
times from five blocks.
It's prized for its Ichimon,
Bokashi, [inaudible],
I've got several examples
here and the one highlighted
in yellow is the one that
we can view in the print.
So, this kind of straight
line color gradation
across the top here you
can barely see it there,
that challenging technique.
The calibration of overall
color across the three sheets,
so these each of these
is printed individually.
But the color of the ocean
at the different points,
the ocean line here this all
has to coordinate together.
As well as the curved lines that
are meant to resemble flowers.
Moreover, short of handling the
print holding it up to the light
to examine the multicolor image
on translucent natural paper
and take in its unified
experience of the senses.
Sato maintains we cannot
fully appreciate the work.
From the artisan
standpoint, the materiality
and techniques are not
surprisingly indivisible
from the enjoyment of
the picture they support.
I'd like to push Sato's
claim one step further to add
that accessing the deep
knowledge of woodblock artisans
or shokunin in the Japanese
expression themselves reveals
meaning beyond both the distinct
visual appeal of ukiyo-e
and the techniques
they preserve.
And in a broader scheme I
want to consider a work of art
that is also a sum of its
making is commanding relevance
in an era where so much making
has gone beyond what we can
picture or imagine.
Let me begin by clarifying the
particular contemporary mode
of ukiyo-e production
to which I refer today.
What the Library of Congress
primarily has in its holdings,
although Catherine also
pulled some of what we're --
a similar mode that
we're going to look
at today our ukiyo-e
contemporaneous with the air
in which their designers
created images
and artisans reproduce them.
That is historic prints going
back as far as the Edo period.
But what I focus on this
afternoon involves living
artisans creating new
editions of these prints made
from re-carved and reprinted
ukiyo-e known as fukkokuban.
For the artisans who create
these prints translate a sheet
as a reproduction or even
a facsimile is inaccurate
because each is still
considered an original print in
and of itself being faithful
to the ukiyo-e work by relying
on the original design relying
on the original design go
through various means of
transferring it to new blocks
and yet being reinterpreted
by new sets of hands.
Ukiyo-e fukkokuban produced
at Sato's workshop
follow a similar,
if impossibly exact
process of making
that Edo Period artisans used
to create water-based
multicolored woodblock prints
like a view of Naruto.
The process is commonly
explained in the context
of a quartet of makers,
publisher,
designer, carver and printer.
Orchestrating the production
of an edition of prints,
a publisher, the hanmoto
commissioned an image
from a designer [inaudible] who
passed the draft of the image
over to a single or a team
of specialized carvers
who divide the design into
multiple blocks, sets of blocks
that went to printers surishis
who pulled carefully mixed
pigments 15 to 30 times
for multiple blocks to the same
sheet to complete the process
for an order into the
hundreds of sheets.
And Catherine has very happily
on my part pulled an
Acornian [phonetic] piece
that I think she's going
to put out later and some
of you may well have
seen these before
where it traces the buildup of
blocks from the light colors
until you get these
very brilliant colors,
the very delicate process
of taking that same sheet
and adding an additional
impression to it.
This I thought was another
way of looking at it
where you're looking at the
carver's blocks and the colors.
Each block that sometimes
impressions are taken
of you know can be two, three,
four times for more complex
works in the same field
and then the colors
gradually built up.
For those of you who are
familiar with these blocks,
you've seen them, you work
with them you will also you
know there's detail and story
within the blocks
themselves, so it's also nice
to be able to look at those.
For those of you who you
know may look at these blocks
and not read the clues on
them, but you're curious
and you have questions,
I'd be happy to go look
at them with you afterwards.
That gives you a picture
of the story of making
and then we get to
the final print.
So, this particular story,
this simplified story is
so oft repeated that I wanted
to update it and expand it based
on ukiyo-e production as it has
been transmitted to us today.
But first, glimpses from Edo's
past establishing standards
as designers such as Kitagawa
Utamaro Utagawa Kunisada took it
upon themselves to depict
their flourishing industry.
And some of these
again if you're working
in this field you may well have
seen these, I'm going to look
at these in a very
rapid way today,
but there's extraordinary detail
that tells so many aspects
of what they saw
themselves doing.
So, Utamaro's pair of triptychs
from the series the cultivation
of brocade prints and I've
got these broken up here just
because it's detailed,
so here are the first two
and then the second or
the third sheet of these.
Utamaro characterizes the
production of nishiki-e
or brocade pictures,
brocade meaning multicolor
like the woven brocade
of a kimono obi.
Through the particular work
of the designer, the carver
and then here you have the paper
sizer to the commercial side,
well you have the printing
here and then the novelty shops
that sold these popular
prints and the customers.
The most conspicuous
aspect is Utamaro's pairing,
the woodblock shokunin
by casting them
as delicately wrought
[inaudible],
beauties are courtesans
who of course were a very
popular genre in ukiyo-e.
In a similar tongue-in-cheek
arrangement
of [inaudible] Kunisada
creates this tryptic
and up-to-date parody
of the four classes
where the artisan class
appears as ukiyo-e artisans
who are almost secondary to
the wealth and variety of tools
and materials show that
support their craft.
A variety of brushes, sizing,
paper, wood blocks, mallets,
knives, gouges, chisels,
mallets, Sumi color pigments,
[inaudible] wet stone,
animal glue known as nikawa
and printing and
carving tables designed
to aid physical labor
of each specialty.
Beyond every one of those tools
or materials were
individual artisans trained
in their own particular
specialty
that go beyond this notion
of the quartet, which I just
because I haven't because I
think it's a beautiful book I
wanted to just point this out.
This is a fairly new book
by Julie Davis who's at Penn
and works very deeply in the
art historical stories of prints
and she's also pushing
this notion of this idea
of the quartet that
has defined printmaking
or ukiyo-e making
for a long time.
We have later versions, I've
got my buttons mixed up here,
to become a little
bit more naturalistic
and this I think sort of
animates the physical labor
of the work, it can be
very labor-intensive.
They also include
additional artifacts,
such as the handwoven
encasements of paper over here
and then you have this man with
the cleaver clipping the edges
that was important to
these very clean edges then
when they went off for sales.
The hibachis here that served
both to keep the artisans warm
and to melt down, keep their
nikawa, their glue melted.
And then the functional
accessory of piece is
to the printing table, so this
is something a little more
modest, something that you
would see more probably
in the 10's, 20's, 30's.
And this kind of -- in this
previous example here you can
see the documentation of those
kinds of aspects of the printer
that became very codified
and diagramed later.
Apart from a few illusions
and updates these items
and processes are
still in use today.
What understanding of ukiyo-e
then do woodblock artisans
practicing today impart and how
does their intimate view ascribe
value to what they
produce in this era?
Our first stop for the living
artisan's perspective is Sato
Keizo's shop just behind Kyoto's
old geisha quarters of Gion.
Sixty years ago, Sato's
father Tiazo moved his family
and print studio together
into a typical post-World War
II house constructed of wood
and corrugated aluminum.
A modest signboard above the
door still identifies the
structure as Sato
Woodblock Studio.
Sato himself can only claim to
be a second-generation shokunin
or artisan, a lineage
that is unimpressive
up against the dynastic
handicraft families
that characterize Kyoto.
Technically, however,
Sato descended
from a Tokyo area shokunin
that can be traced back
at least five generations.
And what I have pictured here,
I don't know if the yellow,
the highlight is
coming through here,
but you have his lineage traced.
This was actually
machine printed,
but as you can tell it was
a handwritten genealogy
from the early 1980's when a lot
of the shokunin were dying out
and realized they wanted
to capture these histories.
Of the 70 odd woodblock artisans
who still practice the art
and craft between Tokyo
and Kyoto today three printers
have apprenticed under Sato.
And at this time, he --
excuse me, there we go.
He has four printers, two
male and two females ranging
from their 20's to 50's, three
of whom graduated university
as artists and opted to embark
on apprenticeships instead
and all of whom must
go through the rigor
of learning the refined
skills of printing ukiyo-e.
While the market
for new printings
of ukiyo-e continues downsize
the more famous series
of Hokusai Katshushika, such
as Mr. Nakayama's printing here
and then you can see the very
familiar finished piece here.
One of his fellow
printers Hirai opened with.
They are still required
to study these prints.
And they're commissioned
exercises to continue
to hone the refined skills
of this cultural heritage.
And I just wanted to
share this piece with you
by a Finnish contemporary
artist,
more of a graphic design artist
who has trained extensively
in traditional techniques.
And part of her cache of
teaching tools is these cards
that she's made to represent.
This is only one portion
of the 50 odd techniques
that she herself has
documented and there are those
that extend beyond that.
So, this is the reason so
much of this commissioning
of these old ukiyo-e
are being done today.
Contemporary printers today
approach orders for ukiyo-e
with a consultation
pooling their knowledge
to discern what combination
of techniques is most likely
to achieve the effects
of the original.
And here's one working
in process here
where you have the sample,
this one of the originals
that came probably
from the publisher
who made the request most likely
out of Tokyo or Kyoto today.
And then you have
the prints coming off
where the printer is
checking the color and sort
of the overall flavor of
the print against the one
that they're aiming to recreate.
They examine the
original paper I order
to assess how they should match
it by color, weight and texture
and sometimes they don't
want to match it at all
because in different eras
there were different qualities
of paper and that paper
is one area for example
that has become much
more standardized
because over the years they've
learned what works, what sells,
and above all in this case
for preserving what
is going to last.
They analyze the
color palette based
on an original sample
though do not aim
to reproduce the
exact colors visible,
rather they mix colors they
determine are authentic
to print before fading, as well
as to adapt to current tastes.
They aim for consistency of
each color across an average run
of 70 to 100 prints at a time,
as well as across the entirety
of prints that compose
a particular series.
Above all, is the
collective work
that cannot adhere
solely to a single vision.
The style unique to each artisan
or their [inaudible] infuses
new paintings or new printings
with fresh originality.
A hokusai or [inaudible] to
be sure differs from artisan
to artisan or network of
artisans to network of artisans.
To be able to produce these
prints Sato Studio operates
within a traditional network
of mostly local shokunin
who [inaudible] relies on
additionally for his paper,
brushes, glue, Sumi
and color pigments.
For paper he has a standing
order for a particular variety
of washi known hosho
made of mulberry fiber.
It is handmade by
papermaker Iwano Ichibei
in the neighboring region of
[inaudible] and he's also a part
of the living national treasure,
echelon of shokunin Japanese
so he has a story
behind him as well.
And the papermaking of
this particular village,
particularly this hosho
variety that is so prized
for woodblock printmaking is
of a cultural and a local level
that there's a shrine that is
devoted to celebration of it
with annual festivals
where the fresh sheets
of paper are brought up
to the shrine as a means
of Thanksgiving, so this
is serious business.
Sato is clear about
his preference
for Ichibei's costly paper
over more economical options.
Its consistency of color which
you can see it's difficult here,
but there's a real if you
were to look at this pail
versus someone else's pail
the quality, the color,
the very softness, the
consistency of texture.
Also, the fiber length
and the linkage
of those fibers are critical
to pulling a perfect
impression sheet after sheet.
And you know unlike an artist
who may be seeking something
different, something surprising
or something not precise
across several sheets they want
that perfect turnout, so that
consistent quality is crucial.
For pigments, Sato strolls 300
meters up the main intersection
to Adachi Pigment Shop.
Okay, so we've got Iwano here
with his wife pulling the paper
and you can see the
stacks here and how smooth,
it's difficult again
in this light,
but how smooth that quality is.
And then up the street
from Sato's workshop
you have a pigment shop
and although Adachi here has a
pamphlet exhibiting nearly 50
exquisite color samples true
to the color wheel's claim
or largely true,
it only takes five
to generate the spectrum
of colors in ukiyo-e.
Prussian blue, ocher, carmine
red, a resin like yellow
and iron oxide burnt umber.
Mixing the pigments with nikawa,
here are the commercial versions
of the nikawa, the animal glue,
are also supplied by Adachi
and he supplies it from another
shokunin craft now gone more
industrial in Hyogo Prefecture
where the malodorous substance
was once made from horse bone
by Japanese, Japan's
Burakumin underclass.
Sumi -- here's some
more examples
of the nikawa in
its various forms.
Sumi is another carefully
tended ingredient right
and can be difficult
to deal with.
If the grains are too coarse
Sato explains they do not
generate the fine
[inaudible] necessary
to capture ukiyo-e's bold black
outlines nor evenness of mixture
in order to produce the same
result again, sheet after sheet.
Three decades ago,
Sato met a Mr. Matsui
from the sumi maker Boku-undo
located in nearby Nara.
Sato was determined to calibrate
the portion of [inaudible] black
or soot, the base of
sumi, nikawa and water
to best suit his printing
where today more standard
versions are premixed
to favor the expressive effects
in calligraphy and ink painting,
which there are just so
many more practitioners
so it's being driven by
the market of course.
Matsui mixed up a custom recipe
for Sato that he has used ever
since and you can see
the various mixes here
and then he's got his
bottle of Matsui special mix
that he's pouring from.
In the printer's world
beyond the various brushes,
each with their own purpose
and histories of making
that I'm going to leave
for another time is the
burnishing pad, the baren.
And unlike some of the
other printing tools
that may be considered more
fungible the baren is unique
to Japanese woodblock
printmaking and essential
to executing ukiyo-e's
cache of techniques.
Its curious construction
incorporates two varieties
of bamboo fiber that are rare
today, [inaudible], washi,
bracken root, starch
powder, fermented persimmon,
black lacquer and camellia oil.
The materials are
worked into improbable
and laborious combination
of parts snugly fit together
in a durable disk that
can withstand the pressure
of a printer's hand for decades.
The finished baren is
yet unrevealing though
because its innards
pictured here that's
where the efficacy lies.
The crucial rationale behind
the baren being these nubbins
of this woven bamboo, this
braided bamboo, the [inaudible],
the part that sticks out that
emerged when different braids
of bamboo are coiled
into its tight disk.
These nubbins create multiple
pressure points that pulse
over the woodblock surface
forcing the colorant
into the paper fibers.
Equally critical are
the minute hollow spaces
around the nubbin
simultaneously working to allow
for enough release of pressure
in order to prevent the paper
from sticking to a dampen block.
So, it's a pretty sophisticated
mechanism accomplishing many
things all at once.
Goto Hidehiko, Japan's
only artisan devoted solely
to baren making and he
has a book on the subject,
characterizes the baren as
a tool that doesn't stand
out for its consequentiality,
but in actuality is a tool
that has continued in
use since the Edo Period.
That is to say and this
is how he describes it,
one with a depth that
is packed with wisdom.
Like paper he explains the baren
occupies a hollowed position
in the woodblock
printer's craft.
Where washi is the
ultimate long life medium
to convey the artist's
vision the baren is cast
and as the alter-ego
of the printer,
the trace of the
printer's hand testimony
to the printer's labor,
mark of the [audio breaks].
Goto adds that a good baren
finesses the work of the carver
and I like that it's not all
about the printer it goes back
to the carver by
expressing the hand,
the lines cut by the carver.
Because printers finish an image
by pulling it in brilliant color
to paper with a symbolic
baren their image has come
to represent the
essence of the craft.
But backing up to consider
the block before the print.
Carver Fujisawa Hiroshi
who collaborates
with the Sato Studio on print
commissions has his own take
on woodblock in ukiyo-e.
Fujisawa is considered
number one in Japan,
[inaudible] dai-ichi among
traditional woodblock carvers,
though his beginnings
were modest.
He came to his craft as
one of the last generation
of postwar shokunin
in the mid-1960's
who selected a vocational
path after middle school.
Even though he enjoys reading
art books today he describes
himself as an old-fashioned
type without any education.
When he came of age
as an artisan it would
have been unimaginable
that a shokunin could be
a university graduate.
Fujisawa sees his spiritual
dimension to his craft
through the Japanese
concept of kokoro
or heart mind or mindfulness.
He expresses his kokoro
through transmission
from his dedicated work
of the hand facilitated
by his prize tools, each
with their own handmade story
of course, to the
natural materials
that he handles with them.
As the carver he
approaches his work
to ease the way for the printer.
So, there's this this thinking
of this team along the way
helping each other out,
anticipating areas of the block
where the printer may
encounter difficulties
in effecting particular
techniques
and even manipulating
carved portion
to serve the carver's own
interpretation of the image.
He has that artists in the past
praised carvers and printers
because they had the capacity
to correct the artist's work,
just as a translator has
the possibility of improving
on the original of
the author's text.
But Fujisawa concedes he
would never tell the artist
because the aim was
to please him or her.
In the traditional woodblock
process before the carver was
the planer this shokunin
was essentially a carpenter
who possessed the
specialized skill
to prepare wood especially
for woodblocks.
According to the 1929 handbook
Nishiki-e Carving and Printing
in the Edo Period these
[inaudible] or plank men apart
from harvesting and
aging the wood
to minimize warping produced
blocks in the appropriate size
and thickness specifically
for this industry of
multicolor prints.
But the real expertise came
in the way they applied
different planes,
the planing process to
prepare the woodblock.
Above all, the woodblock had to
be absolutely smooth and even
to avoid any pooling
on its surface,
a condition that neither machine
planing is quite fine enough
to render today nor
can be matched
by substituting present-day
timbers
for building construction.
Like the Chinese gold
standard of pear wood
or [inaudible] the Japanese
preference for [inaudible],
the mountain cherry type
of timber was practical.
It was a plentiful
indigenous timber harvested
from nearby mountains that
offered a suitable hardness
to facilitate carving while
still supporting the hairpin
relief in ukiyo-e in
sustaining the wear
and tear of large print runs.
And I noticed some of the prints
that Catherine pulled today,
these hairpin lines,
I mean there were some
that were even thinner than
a hairpin I think in some
of the patterns on
the textile designs.
So, when you go out just zero in
on the fineness of those lines
and that the cherry
wood can withstand
that so those little
pieces don't pop off.
Fujisawa considers
[inaudible] Japanese magnolia,
another desirable hardwood,
although he declares
it's no good for Utamaro.
[Inaudible] further he
suggests another variety,
a type of boxwood known as
tsuge also pleasantly hard,
but the trouble with [inaudible]
lies in the trunk diameter
that only matures about
15 to 20 centimeters.
So, you know, if you're doing
small prints that works,
but in the standard
of this oban size,
the standard ukiyo-e size
it's simply too small.
So, you can see how all of these
things come down to us today.
Unlike Western-style engraving
that uses that horizontal cut
on the top the custom of
ukiyo-e is a vertical cut,
and specifically an outside,
the outer side of a tree trunk.
There are more practical
reasons for this,
among them being the vertical
cut with its alignment
of green made a block softer
and easier to carve enabling
for speed and quick turnover,
which is less an issue today
but it was an issue
when this was a vibrant
commercial practice.
Once Fujisawa puts knife
to block he must assess the
block's grain at every juncture.
Unlike the composition
of steel for instance,
internally the wood possesses
a unique pattern of growth
and fibers can deviate from
the straight growth creating an
internal composition
of a mix of grains.
Fujisawa sees his challenge
in the individual
nature of block poses.
He characterizes
it as a face-off
between nature and human skill.
Carving into the grain of course
can be damaging to the wood
and works against
the cut of the knife.
Carving with the grain the
knife moves along in parallel.
So, Fujisawa feels his
way across the block
as he wields his knife,
anticipating these internal
traffic jams in the wood.
One true test of the overall
quality of woodblock print lies
in these inked-out lines, the
[inaudible], the curved lines.
And if any of you have had
the experience of going
through an ukiyo-e exhibition
around Japan I've observed
that viewers this is one of
the areas where they sigh
and they pause over this moment
of these beautiful curved lines.
Although computer
technology can now aid
in carving these lines Fujisawa
hazards it's not the same
movement as the human hand.
Therein lies his
conceptualization of kokoro,
this mindfulness, as
it ties to his craft.
Lest his arguments sound
dubious he proceeds,
when he carves a masterwork he
may be transported into the mind
of an artist and effectively
be able to read them.
The physical process also
yielding a spiritual connection
if you will that a
computer cannot facilitate.
In contrast, when he observes
computer-generated print designs
he believes their feeling,
their [inaudible] isn't good.
Even if an artist
approaches a project
with certain intent the
mediating computer disables
dimensions of the human idea.
He believes there's an
infinitely more variation
and nuance to the types of
lines humans can create.
A computer-generated image of a
chrysanthemum for instance maybe
so finely executed
that it is impossible
for a human hand to carve.
But if the human hand depicts
these lines it will only draw
what can physically
it can manage,
thereby vesting the
rendering of the blossom
with a subjective expression.
And I think this is where
that's when people are sighing
at these curved lines, you
know there's that transfer,
that feeling of something
ineluctably human
if you will about
that execution.
And in a case where the artist
fails to be as successful
in depicting lines the carver
can go in and improve the work.
Or simply put, there's something
accessible and authentic
about an image whose composition
and production we can
finesse ourselves.
I'd like to come full circle
to consider Sato Keizo's
selection of a view of Naruto.
Like many ukiyo-e landscapes
it's a pleasing image in itself.
The landscape also appeals
because like larger-than-life
Mount Fuji it maintains
contemporary significance.
Hiroshige's scenic portrayal
of the tidal whirlpools
in the Naruto Strait can still
be witnessed today in a channel
between Naruto in
Tokushima and Awaji Island.
Art historically the print's
content also offers its own
narrative, it's believed
to be one
of the three tryptics Hiroshige
created in his last year
of life observing the theme
sun, moon and flowers,
the whirlpool rapids whimsically
depicting the flower theme.
There is in short, much
to be made of it revered
as a pretty picture
and a visual work
that these days we can consume
for free in any proximity
of a screen or a museum
shot or for real here.
So, the crux of the question
remains, does the making matter
as long as we enjoy
the visual image?
Japanese woodblock printing is
often discounted among Japan's
rich tradition of
arts and crafts,
devoid of any explicit use value
like a ceramic tea bowl
or a bamboo basket.
Historically viewed as a
reproductive technology rather
than a refined craft its
artisans also haven't always
made the annals of
traditional Japanese arts.
But ukiyo-e comes to us
today both as historic prints
and refined artworks because
of the vast compendium
of hand techniques and the
[inaudible] materials it
integrates in order to
create a single sheet.
Through the artisans
who preserve it today
ukiyo-e are documents
of living culture beyond
their visual value,
that such a universally
appealing image is still
generated primarily of organic
materials almost exclusively
with human hands and by a
community of local individuals
who know one another, are
values of making and of living
and working that
offer new relevance
in the virtual worlds of today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yes.
>> Fascinating, thank you.
>> Clair Cuccio: Thank you.
>> Can you tell me a
little bit about the market
for the [inaudible], I'm
sorry if I mispronounced that
and also, what is the method of
transfer of the original print
to this contemporary reprint?
>> Clair Cuccio: Okay the
[inaudible] market that reprint,
I'm not saying reproduction
or facsimile
because I'm trying
to [inaudible].
Okay, excuse me.
Are you speaking at the
present day or across time?
>> Presently.
>> Clair Cuccio: Presently.
They're still issued
through publishers,
publishers are often bookstores.
I mean sometimes I think
that sense of the publisher
in the Western context it's
not clear, but publishers,
bookstores will issue special
series at certain times
of the year in a kind
of celebratory mode that's
becoming a little more esoteric.
And so, people who know of
the may go seeking them out,
but they're not big
sellers today.
There was a vigorous industry
postwar I think in the 20's
and 30's as well
where newspapers
and some other industries
would if you subscribed
to them they would
you know deliver,
you would receive your free --
like the New Yorker does today
with its bags, you know they
would issue a free series
or you'd collect
prints over time
if you maintained
your subscription.
But that has for the
most part eroded,
that does come around
occasionally.
But that would have to be
something today very high-end
where you're actually going
to get that handmade print.
They might do those today in
some form of laser printing
that is still appealing,
but doesn't have, you know,
that despite virtue of
costs it's impossible.
So, the market today is often
museums, libraries those
that have a particular research
or connoisseur interest in them,
but so much of what's
driving it today is
if we don't do you know
we forget how to do it.
And that is a valid market, if
a very limited one in itself.
>> And how are the
original prints transferred?
>> Clair Cuccio: Okay there
are varieties of methods.
If you're going to observe, if
a shokunin, an artisan is going
to observe a carver because
it's the carver who would
who would do this phase of
the making they will have --
at this stage they're not
of course getting an
original from a designer.
So, what they would have
and this would likely come
from the -- it wouldn't come
from the carver it might come
from a printer who has
these in a collection,
a personal collection.
But more likely it will come
directly from the publisher
who will have a library,
a cache of these originals
that date back to
different times.
They will send that original
along and they can create,
today they'll do, there are
different laser processes
that can be done, but the
traditional style would be
to take that image and
photograph it in some way,
reproduce it, reverse
onto the print.
And then if it's the
traditional version it's a
paper reproduction.
>> That part of the
production I understand,
I was just wondering
today how they take an old
conventional print.
>> Clair Cuccio: Print.
>> And then take that image and
transfer it onto a new block.
>> Clair Cuccio: Right
and sometimes that's done
electronically, digitally,
and sometimes if they
have an additional print
that they can just trash
they will so to speak,
they will glue that
to the block.
And they'll -- if we go back
to some of the block images,
if I can get back there quickly.
You can actually see
in these traditional,
this traditional process
where it's been glued,
the print has been glued
in the reverse to the block
and then it's peeled away
and it leaves the lines.
>> We had a lot of blocks
with the [inaudible].
>> Clair Cuccio: Right, so here
is the paper still there right.
And so, if they're observing an
absolutely traditional method
that would be the
way that it's done.
Let's see if there are any, I
think there were some others.
Yeah, you can still
see the little smidgens
of paper there on the edges.
>> Thank you.
>> Clair Cuccio: Thank you.
Other questions or input, I
mean I'm really interested apart
from the very specific nature
of this talk if this moves you,
if you buy into this
perspective.
I imagine a fair number of you
are in the world of art history.
I'm coming from this more from
a sociological perspective
from an interest in how
art is used and circulates.
So, please speak up.
Catherine.
>> It's a good segue.
So, you're very erudite
and knowledgeable
in the world of mokuhanga.
I think of this now as being
an international phenomenon,
is that fair to say or would you
say there are stronger centers
or communities or can you
talk a little bit about that?
>> Clair Cuccio: Yes, so
mokuhanga is the Japanese term
that means objectively
and literally wood impression
picture, woodblock print.
But it has been disseminated
from Japan today,
in the last 20 years by a
group particularly interested
in preserving the shokunin,
the artisan techniques
through an approach of
sort of sending them
out with the idea being
that there aren't that many,
there is a limited
number of artisans,
there are a limited number
of art students who in Japan
who are interested in this mode.
And so, if we let it
free we send it out,
somewhat like ukiyo-e when
they migrated to Europe
and they were sort of discovered
there and then they came back
to Japan and Japan
realized oh wow,
we do have something really
special here that we discounted
as you know just popular art.
This movement started to happen
with a small group of people,
there are residencies there in
mokuhanga in woodblock prints
that are based on these
traditional techniques
with the idea being, not that
they stay the same, not the work
of the artisan where
you're trying
to reproduce the same
techniques, but to innovate
and take the base of these
techniques and the base
of these materials and
to create something new.
And yes, there is
a greater movement,
there's an American artist based
in New York, April Vollmer,
if any of you are in the print
world you're probably familiar
with her.
She has a very active website,
V-O-L-L-M-E-R is the last name.
She came out with a book
two years ago that looked
at very specific development
interest in the form
of mokuhanga appropriating
some traditional techniques
in North America, artists,
contemporary artists
who are using these forms.
And it's a beautiful book
to look at, the latter half
of the book are images
of 50 odd artists
who are working in these modes.
So that's a whole
another dimension of this.
And there is some exchange
between these artisans
who occasionally
will collaborate
with contemporary artists.
You know the issue in
Japan is the cost of labor.
But if you somehow can
make that happen and if any
of you are familiar with
the work of Rebecca Salter
who does a lot of -- out
of the UK, she does a lot
of ink painting and maybe
better known for that.
But she studied in Japan
at Kyoto Seika University
where three of the artisans
working with Sato graduated.
She was there working
with Kurosaki Akira
who also is another contemporary
artist using traditional
Japanese print techniques.
So again, if you're in that
field you may know his work
as well.
She was studying with him,
became very interested
in a shokunin culture and
supporting these people.
And so, she is now in a kind of
you know position as an artist,
a mature artist to
collaborate with them.
And did a show where
she did the paintings
and then they interpreted
them into print.
And if anybody has interest
in that it's a beautiful
and fabulous project and
I'd be happy to point you
to some resources
to look at that.
>> Thank you.
>> Clair Cuccio: Thank you.
>> Eiichi Ito: Last
question if you have?
>> Clair Cuccio: Go ahead.
If there are other questions
I'm happy to take them,
I think there's one
in front, go ahead.
>> So actually, I have two
questions which are related,
one is a more detailed
technical question,
the other is more big
picture, sociological question.
You mentioned about
some of them using,
could be using electronic
technology.
When they compare their
printing the color,
check the color are they still
using their naked eye to check
or they are using some
kind of tools to help?
So that lead to the second
question is when you talk
to these people, when you
interview them [inaudible]
or talking to these people
are they really worried,
for example while some of
them are become living legends
and they are the only
person in their own world
to still keep this skill?
Are they worried
about losing their?
>> Clair Cuccio: You
mean the preservation
of what they have accumulated?
So, the first question regarding
the assessment of color,
those that I have dealt with
I don't think in the workshop,
in these studios there
isn't that degree
of technical assessment
of a print.
There are chemists and
there are art historians
with chemically minded projects
where there is technology
to do the interpretation,
to interpret.
And there may well be some of
you here that deal with that
if not in prints in some other
mode where they, you know,
they analyze it and see
what exactly you know this
composition was of
this particular color
and how many layers are
to it and all of that.
But no, it's more, I think
it's just familiarity
with seeing these things over
and over again and again.
You know it comes back to Sato
saying, you know your best form
of study is with the original
work, it's that idea, you know,
the idea of repetition
and exposure.
On the skills and losing
them, I can't speak
for that specifically from the
people with whom I've dealt
with because none is
carrying that sense
of being the last one on earth.
Goto Hidehiko, the baren maker,
he didn't descend from a line
of baren makers, in many
ways he was self-taught,
but has preserved you know
through what he knows.
There is, you know, there is
a fair amount of documentation
to be able to preserve
these things.
I'm trying to think, is there
anyone else here who deals
in craft in Japanese
living national treasures?
It is an issue and there's a
very practical issue of interest
on the part of people,
I mean Japanese directly
although some --
there has been some
studios in different areas
and this is beyond prints,
have been approached
by foreigners who've
wanted to apprentice.
But when you're not selling your
items you don't have a market
unless you have some means to
find and there are some people,
there's a German carver,
I'm speaking too long,
who are interested --
who's interested in
becoming a traditional carver
and I think he's in a
situation where he's able
to fund part of it for himself.
But a lot of it comes
down to economics.
I'm happy, I believe
you had a question,
I'm happy to take it afterwards.
>> Eiichi Ito: [Inaudible],
so that's the last question.
>> Actually, I think
you answered it,
mostly about how are
new people educated,
but I think you addressed
it with learning
from what's written
and other historical.
>> Clair Cuccio: I think
that the problem of exposure
and learning, I think there's
a fair amount that's available
for those who are curious and
really you know are devoted,
who you know sort of
apprenticeship level commitment.
But the question in Japan in
particular is the mainstream
and there are students today,
young people who look at these
as elsewhere and
they're familiar with it
because these images
are so, they see them.
But they can't comprehend
how they were made.
And one of the educated, very
mainstream educational aspects
that has shifted in Japan
is that these woodblock,
I mean when you were in
school did you do you know
mokuhanga prints?
Yeah, everybody, this is part
of the curriculum, every kid.
Did you [inaudible],
you probably?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Oh, okay that's right.
>> Eiichi Ito: Much older,
so I don't know [inaudible].
>> Clair Cuccio: But until about
10 years ago you had it in fifth
or sixth grade and then
again in middle school
and again in high school.
So, typically you
had three shots
at the carving, using
the knives.
Part of it is part of the
shift where it's been axed
from curriculums is a common
problem throughout the world
and that's increased
content to be exposed
to time, it's a slow craft.
So, it's easier to do you know
craft with Styrofoam or linocut
or something like that.
And I think as you
know this being
in this American venue we can
appreciate Japanese parents are
worried about the danger
of knives, that's also come
up as a reason why they don't
want them in schools anymore.
So, this question of education
comes at many tiers and each
of those I think
is sociologically,
culturally very interesting.
Thank you very much.
I'd be happy to take
thoughts on making, on craft,
on your own interests
if you're artists,
art historian's perspective,
please your time permitting
approach me afterwards.
Thank you so much.
>> Yes, as you walk out
there's a display ready for you,
so please enjoy viewing
those materials.
Thank you very much, thank you.
>> Clair Cuccio: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.